so neon is a young streamer and he does
streams with Bradley Martin I've seen
him do stuff with a blue face um I've
seen him I even just saw a clip of him
with Charlie demilio the other day um
and really he he's probably worth
millions and millions of dollars as a
young kid and he decided
to wife up an only fans model and they
sort of went viral in the last couple of
weeks because she took a lie detector
test and she said she has not seen
anybody since they've been talking and
that she has been celibate you know
there's been other Clips going viral
basically saying that she is not
sleeping with him but she is on only
fans and now it's coming out that neon
tells Aiden Ross that he believes his
girlfriend when she said she slept in
the same bed as another guy and didn't
have sex with him let's pull it
up but I I basically just said today
that Sam flew out a guy in Vegas and
they
um during when rice C got swatted and
then they had breakfast that morning
together and I just wanted to know man
you know neon is texting my phone saying
dude Aiden I promise you they didn't
they just slept together you know what
I'm saying and I think that's he's being
in denial um because obviously she's
like don't worry NE we didn't [__] we
didn't [__] we just slept together and
you know whether they were serious or
not chat it's still a red flag S I want
to know your take on that whole thing I
know okay um yeah look so we both know
that's [__] like a girl says that
like you're flying a dude if a girl's
flying a dude out when I fly a chick out
I expect [__] if I'm gonna fly out for
a chick like I'm doing anal it's took a
lot of heat cuz and I actually when I
first heard this I was sort of triggered
too but he he had a clip that went viral
and he said if a girl doesn't sleep with
you on the first sec I think it was
first second date maybe even first date
he said tell her to get out and the
reason being is men don't want to be
dragged around like this they don't want
to find out later that the girl they're
seeing that made them wait hopped right
into bed and even flew out another guy
and that's you know and I as a girl I I
know girls will come in and they'll say
you have a right to say no and you
totally do but this is just how men see
it and I don't know why he's really
taking an only fans model seriously it
kind of brings him in views so you know
whatever I guess there's one more video
hold up babe all right babe you're
you're you're getting nervous now it's
bait but look he just needs to grow up
he'll make the mistake with you and then
I'll be seeing you're getting nervous
and again this is where the tradcon
advice and I don't say this in a happy
way guys I don't say this like I'm super
happy about it but I really want you to
see more where some of these pickup guys
are coming from the reason they say
things like you need to have sex with
her as soon as possible the reason
they don't really have a lot of patience
in that department is stuff like this
because women will drag these guys
around women with more sexual experience
that know the game better than the guys
and take advantage of men that do not
know better and you know men are kind of
sick of being taken advantage of um but
unfortunately I do think this is kind of
the future now let's look at the
comments they said if we're being real
neon corny for just sitting there and
let some other dude speak for his
relationship he fried her
though next comment says they forgot to
include Adam 22
convers no
um British homie is a real man standing
up for a fellow man being taken
advantage of mad respect Albi the entire
situation is a bit stupid in the first
place so you know neon's free to choose
what he wants to do um and I I think
eventually these relationships when
they're younger they don't last anyways
um but I I do you know there's
consequences when you date an only
fans's model and the past will always
come back to haunt you if she's willing
to do it once why why would she not do
it again